[Música]
a
pues yo también vengo a hacer una
confesión
hace tres años que me conozco mejor
dicho tres años que me reconozco si
tenía las mismas piernas las mismas
manos y el mismo nombre que ahora pero
tenía un problema
es que no era capaz de escucharme no era
capaz de conectar conmigo misma
quiero hacer una pregunta cuántos de los
que estáis hoy aquí habéis sentido
estrés al menos una vez este año por
favor levantar la mano
gracias
aquí y ahora me gustaría compartir con
vosotros parte de mi historia y a la vez
una reflexión y un deseo y es que juntos
podamos viajar en un mundo en el que
cada vez se hace más necesario
desconectar para volver a conectar y así
seguir avanzando
volvamos a tres años atrás podríamos
decir que mi vida era estupenda
trabajaba en el área digital de un gran
grupo de televisión vivía una ciudad
maravillosa como madrid y tenía la
suerte de vivir en un estupendo ático en
el centro de la ciudad
pero por lo que fuera mi sensación era
de vacío
vivimos en un mundo cambiante estamos
constantemente recibiendo estímulos
podemos decir que vivimos en un estado
de sobre estimulación
y esto se ve exponencialmente
incrementado por el mundo digital
gracias a él podemos comunicarnos
aprender pero a la vez corremos el
riesgo de informarnos porque el mundo
digital
está creado con muchos objetivos entre
otros el de recabar datos información y
ofrecernos productos a medida de
nuestras preferencias y esto abarca
también a las ideas
la conexión es la razón fundamental para
nosotros
y compartir comunicarnos y el mundo
digital nos apasiona porque nos permite
explorar lo exponencialmente
por poner un ejemplo según el informe de
este año de hootsuite a día de hoy somos
más de 4.300 millones de internautas en
el mundo esto viene siendo más o menos
un 52% de la población y el 57% se
conecta vía móvil
la media mundial de conexión diaria es
de dos horas al día os imagináis cuál es
la media de conexión diaria en españa'
es cinco horas y media si somos
especialistas en romper estadísticas
e
[Música]
el mundo digital nos abre muchas
posibilidades
ay qué nos pasa cuando estamos tan
predispuestos a recibir información ya
conectarnos digitalmente pues corremos
el riesgo de desconectarnos nosotros y
ser vulnerables a la manipulación
carlas vilarroya tiene un libro que se
llama somos lo que nos contamos y nos
explica que hay tres factores
fundamentales para la expansión de ideas
falsas la primera de ellas es una
situación de estrés o agobio la segunda
de ellas es la predisposición humana
a querernos con teorías conspiranoicas y
la tercera de ellas es la burbuja
narrativa lo que en literatura se llama
la suspensión de la incredulidad
giordano bruno decía se non è vero è ben
trovato si no es verdad está bien
encontrado un librepensador que acabó
quemado en la hoguera
las claves para que se expandan estas
ideas son eficacia y oportunidad y como
hemos visto estamos en un mundo en el
que hay estrés y somos un caldo de
cultivo para ello
volvamos pues a tres años atrás lo único
que tenía claro en aquel momento lo
único que sabía es que el equilibrio
entre mi motor intrínseco y la vida que
yo llevaba
no existía y como os podéis imaginar
madrid y la gran metrópoli no es el
mejor lugar para escucharse así que
decidí dejarlo todo e irme sola viajar
por el mundo
y a
de repente me vi en australia en nueva
zelanda en indonesia en japón incluso en
el desierto de nevada
en el ver ni mamá
estamos en el siglo 21 y a día de hoy
una mujer como yo puede viajar sola hace
unos 50 años igual hubiera sido
impensable y mucho antes igual hubiera
quemado que hubiera acabado como
giordano bruno quemada en la hoguera
qué es lo que sucedió cuando me fui pues
necesitaba necesitaba desconectar
necesitaba tener tiempo para pensar para
escucharme para sentirme para saber que
quería pero a la vez necesitaba estar
conectada sentía la necesidad de seguir
conectada con el resto del mundo
especialmente con galicia y con coruña
que es donde está mi familia en mis
seres queridos y mi cultura y con mucha
gente que he conocido en estos años a
través de mis redes sociales tanto
personales como profesionales
conseguí encontrar este espacio
y poco a poco fue viniendo a mí
y experimentar cada día el sentir el
encontrar mis motores intrínsecos
digamos que cada uno de nosotros tenemos
unos motores intrínsecos eso que nos
hace estar bien para poder compartir y
crear que al final es el motor que mueve
el mundo es como una deportista que se
prepara el mejor nivel para jugar en
equipo o alguien que se dedica a la
música ensaya con su banda para ofrecer
el mejor concierto
digamos que cada uno tenemos nuestros
motores y en mi caso pues pues es
galicia
y es aquí cuando tenemos el
autoconocimiento real de nosotros mismos
y lo combinamos con el mundo digital
donde empieza a aparecer la magia
digamos que una vez que nosotros nos
conocemos nos encontramos con el círculo
que se puede aplicar tanto a personas
como a organizaciones de personas y es
que lo importante es pararse para poder
crear para poder compartir
esto el mundo digital nos permite poder
hacerlo conocer vivir donde queramos
comunicarnos
y a la vez poder dar lo mejor de
nosotras y nosotros mismos para hacer un
mundo mejor y esto funciona así tanto en
nueva york como mondoñedo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]